hello and welcome to insight Germany
my guest today is a legend of the
underground music scene here in Berlin
who arrived from Manchester in northern
England way back in 1978 when this city
was divided by its notorious wall that
didn't deter musician and record
producer mark reader who managed to
organize the first secret punk rock
concert in communist East Berlin and he
got away with it however he was soon
labeled subversive by the Stasi the East
German secret police but he's here to
tell that tale and hopefully many more a
man so well connected in the music
business his telephone book no doubt
makes interesting reading you've also
got a brand new album at
hot-off-the-press
in fact they're still warm I can feel
them which we'll be giving away a couple
of copies signed copies of these later
in the program
welcome to show wanted to ask you first
of all I worked out if my math is
correct that you came to Germany when
you were still a teenager back in 1978
with no German you didn't speak German
at all so what was the incentive to
suddenly up sticks from good old
Manchester beans in Manchester in that
intent a bit better I came here I've
been to Germany in 1776 first time was
about eighteen and I just kind of liked
the idea that it was something a bit
different to what I've been used to in
Manchester and I just decided to come
and just see what was what Berlin was
about you know I travelled a bit around
West Germany and then decided to take
the train to Berlin which I I got a
train as far as that Hannover some place
on and missed the connection and I'm
standing in the pouring rain thinking to
myself like how do I get to Berlin now
it's almost quite late at night and that
guy on the platform to serve all right
take the regional train and then get off
and just watch the border and you can
hitchhike to Berlin's which is exactly
what I did
because this we should explain Berlin
was sort of this island in the middle of
communist East Germany yeah and what you
you went to the border mmm I watched the
border walk to the board and got a lift
yeah in a West German car it has to be
said because you does some student guy
was just on his way to all the cars
going from West Germany we're going to
Berlin yes so souls were only three
roads when it was desolate and and I had
no idea what I was really doing I just
decided that's a try this out you know
so on the suggestion that you could just
get a car to Berlin so I did yeah but
did you also come because of the music
here well yeah it was mainly one of the
thing not because of the music here um I
was interested in German electronic
music had been kind of infected as a
teenager listening to things like
tangerine dream and Klaus Schulze and
things like this and odd craft fur and a
calf work definitely you know and and
and and also I'll be working in Virgin
Records in this tiny little record shop
in Manchester this is before the the
Richard Branson boom of megastores and
thinks it was a small record shop work
there's a kind of part-time and
eventually got a proper job there and I
worked there for a while and always
looking at these imports from German
it's always like good quality of
pressings great you know like sounding
records I thought you know a very
different kind of mindset of what we had
in the UK and I was quite interested in
expanding my knowledge on this
electronic music stuff and I just
decided I was going on check it out
myself that's why I went to initially
went to Germany in the first place to
chat to find out what if I could find
records that were not available in the
record shop in Manchester that's a long
way to come when you got here I get the
impression here we are in this little
island of capitalism if you die in West
Berlin but freedom but you seem to be
more interested in the East things
nobody could tell me anything about
Berlin and Manchester certainly no one
knew anything about Berlin pattern that
we bombed it to bits and it was like
this light and city which was surrounded
by a wall and everyone
apparently depressed here and the the
fact that most people actually thought
that Germany was like this and it was
divided in the middle in Berlin kind of
separated both sides east and west you
know they didn't realize that Berlin was
actually in the middle of East Germany
most some people people thought it was
like North and South Berlin you know so
I thought I'll cut off check out for
myself you know find out what's going on
here myself and just went and came and
found it it was a completely different
place altogether but all the Berlin is
that I'm in the first couple of days
that I've met people on street low and
nobody could tell me anything about East
Berlin really it's all it was they were
all kind of really negative and I
thought I'll have to go and check out
for myself and people couldn't even tell
me or you can go to checkpoint charlie
you know I found I found that out by
meeting a West German who'd actually
stopped me to ask me where the
Brandenburg Gate was and then we got
talking he was all you can go over
checkpoint charlie so I went to
checkpoint charlie and went over to East
Berlin I was like yeah this was the
Allied checkpoint wasn't it was we had
to go three house bombers yeah yeah we
couldn't go we could go over
Friedrichstrasse er which I didn't know
at that time or Checkpoint Charlie I'll
check on Charlie but then look like a
petrol station without petrol pumps you
know it was like this is exact like
little walkway which was cordoned off
and all these barriers and that kind of
like mice is very strange you get in
this like cubicle and it's all these
like potted plants in like Formica
potted plants and pictures of like
Brandenburg and Magdeburg painted in the
18th century on the walls kind of you
know it was all kind of wallpaper in
kind of like tried to make look kind of
homely when you got into this kind of
like control point and some guys sitting
there and at least you know he's German
border guard smoking a cigarette and
looking at if possible you know what
you're doing here yeah yeah I thought
it's very it was very very weird and
getting to East Berlin and it was
completely different I wanted to show
this picture because this is in East
Berne and this is that [ __ ] the first
May Day celebrations and if you can't if
I don't know whether that you can really
see him but that's Hanukkah there isn't
it on the is directly in the middle is
Erich Honecker and really stuff and I
was I'd gone to this parade to
you to see you know see the foot the May
Day Parade and where's your camera
I know where we kappa by mean this is
mm-hmm and I thought oh I saw these
people just kind of walked along I
thought I'll just go and have a walk you
know see what it's like to walk in the
May Day Parade in East Berlin and I got
in this parade and started walking at
that time I didn't realize that it was
all organized that all these people who
were actually ended up actually
participating it was all organizing some
way by kind of like the companies that
they work father like the factories that
they'd work for organized all the
families to go along and wave carnations
and support me you know the sdd and I
just kind of walked in there and I
thought I'm getting closer iconic I'll
take a photograph you know I thought my
camera upset the photographing just as I
press the shutter that's why the falter
got a little bit blurred I was unwrapped
from like this all sides that I didn't
realize at the time but as I walk and
entered this parade immediately I've
been surrounded by Stasi blokes in
leather jackets and moustaches you know
and they just grabbed me and just hauled
me off I've kind of interrogated me for
like half an hour you know what you're
doing where have you come from you know
go and see my passport and house like oh
dear I'm gonna get put into her wine
well no I thought it's quite it's
darling you know it was quite exciting
you've got lots of stories let's find
out more though now the other day mark
took us on a nostalgic journey around
his Berlin it's a lovely quiet Sunday
morning and I'm going to take you to a
few places that have been important to
me Berlin of the last couple of decades
so come with me you know take you there
I came to Berlin in 1978 one of the
first places I came to was the
Brandenburg Gate and it looked very
different back then
there was a lovely little wall around it
separating East from West it was nothing
like it imagine the Berlin Wall to be in
fact I thought it was going to be this
huge like you know 16-foot brick wall
made out of red bricks and when I got to
see it I was quite wow it looks really
flash this photograph that I hold in my
hands it's a picture of me trying to
escape to East Berlin
we're standing here in Kreuzberg behind
me is the legendary SL 36 club which was
the place where I first played in Berlin
with a band I had no idea what I was
going to do and I can a friend of mine
Allister he called me just to see if I
wanted to go out for a drink and I said
to him hey Allister can you sing any way
through dynamite brilliant we've got a
gig next Wednesday when we call by a
journalist the undercount in England
there which became shortened to the
umber concen which actually means the
unknown we went to buy some beer sir
could drink some liquid courage than
then we came to play in this place
I'm standing in front of the reminder
house of the a loser Curia in Rome
ellsberg which images in the East Berlin
de toten hosen a punk band from West
Germany played the first gig by a
western group here in East Berlin in
1982 we invited our only 100 people
cloak very very close friends and and
everyone was so excited because this was
you know this but they admired the band
they already knew the music by the band
they'd heard it on the radio so the
other day already knew who they were but
to actually see them perform in their
own country
you know something which was illegal and
we all knew it was really highly illegal
it meant so much more than just the
normal gig in a normal club anywhere in
the world and especially for these kids
because we've managed to bring someone
from the West so then because they
couldn't come to see us in the work in
the world they were not allowed to leave
East Germany it brought tears to my eyes
honestly I couldn't believe it I was
like I could believe that we actually
pulled it off and got away with doing
this gig without the authorities finding
out but this is the only place in on our
little tour that as hasn't changed at
all
this is the chisel or this is the place
which used to be the truth or
unfortunately tore it down a couple of
years back this Rizal was one of
Berlin's most famous take no clubs of
the 90s everyone and everybody who was
in a techno DJ wanted to play there
because it gave them a status in this
area anything goes you know there was
there are no rules of no regulations
there's no policing in the early 90s it
was a very unique club and a really
really great place to go out to and
there's nothing gonna be like it ever
again there's nothing gonna be by ever
again I'll put you up on that a little
later my readers my guests I didn't
actually ask you I'd said your musician
and producer but when you came to Berlin
yeah
how did you get into the music scene
well I've been designated the factory
records German representative by Rob
Gretton and Tony Wilson who just started
this record label in Montrose in
Manchester The Joy Division yeah it was
basically for them and really in the
news in many ways so it was like they
were mates and it was well giving
Germany now can you promote our records
in Germany would you would you be
prepared to do this upside out so they
could put on their things Berlin totally
told me like years later the only reason
why he wanted it because I wanted to
have on the on the letterhead and
Manchester New York Brussels Berlin
because it looked good on paper
that's awful okay well but you know I
just did the promotion for them really
at the beginning and it kind of opened
up a lot of doors I think a lot of
people thought that maybe some
association to what with me would maybe
get them a record deal with factory or
sometime I don't know what is that how
you met toten hosen because we should
explain talk knows and maybe not when
I'm gonna ask you about this gig in the
east maybe they were there huge I mean
their Stadium band today aren't they and
they have been for quite a time yeah
yeah but then they were just starting
really it was like one of the early
earlier gigs they don't done really a
handful of gigs I kind of met them by
and the singer I
I was at the time managing and I was the
sound engineer for a group called
malaria yeah
malaria was like an avant-garde girl
group Gudrun got some Bettina Custer's
band and we done this festival kind of
concert in bottom with Neubauten andreas
doll and my driver was campy know the
singers torn holes now and he was
talking about this new band that he had
and you know they were looking you know
playing games and stuff and looking
forward to what was even this the toten
hosen means the dead trousers and these
trousers they bought in a shopping like
you buy per kilo like 16 kilos of
trousers for like about what mark or
something horrible hideous flares from
India and Andy the bass player he kind
of registers himself at my flat so that
he could escape going to the German army
and he would then load up all these cuff
these trousers in my flat anyway so I've
kind of got into this salt and holes and
thing know I became their sound engineer
that but how did you get the gig in East
Berne how did you do that in that you
were saying earlier going through
Friedrichstrasse er this is the
underground station or through
checkpoint charlie but how did you get
all over there with guitars equipment
nothing like that it was nothing like
that people like you know because the
only place and strange-looking I mean
he's yeah photo I mean we saw the photo
briefly in in in in the report but
there's a motley crew well the two girls
at the front of the photograph they were
my East German contacts they were girls
that I'd met and I met in when I first
got to East Berlin I met this funky
looking kid on the underground and I
asked him do is there any place here
where there are any underground events
happening and at that time I didn't know
it was from the Stasi but actually he
was an official amitabh I so you know is
it an informer
but he passed on the I gave him my
address I said if you do have any gigs
or anything just just calm it you know
just write me a postcard and months
later I got a postcard from these girls
saying come and visit me meet me in East
Berlin so I met
got chatting and these girls weren't
from the sea not really no they were
just friends abyss and he kind of passed
on this information because he knew they
like this think that the idea was to get
me to come over to sound me out really
and they had they were John Peel fans
they were really like obsessed by his
shell because it it kind of gave them
something which he couldn't get in East
Germany which was freedom of thought you
know freedom of choice and most probably
heard on be FPS the FPS under us world
service yeah because I used to watch and
so they had they had they would
religiously recall every show that he
that you've made actually and they were
kind of interested in what was going on
in West Berlin and in England and things
and and and meeting in a real English
person stuff was for them some acquire
thrill over the years you know like then
a couple years later when I started to
work with toten hosen I met this hippie
in a Baja who told me about this
so-called Blues mrs. lippett it which is
a like a blues mass that they held in a
church and every other Sunday I thought
what's that because yeah just I've got a
guitar electric guitar one in East
Germany shouldn't just buy an electric
guitar in a shop and play right but he
hadn't acquired an electric guitar and
he played you know Bob Dylan songs or
whatever in this church and I thought
wonder if it's possible to kind of like
expand this theory and this idea of
plane and get a band to play instead and
we went to see the priest at the church
and music I see this is before the
possible if a band came over to play
would they be able to play and he's like
well you know possibly and so it kind of
would surround this kind of idea of like
okay we need to get some instruments
because the band obviously can't bring
their own instruments into East Berlin
we'll have to get acquire some
instruments and so we did a few bands
like these girls knew like plan loss and
feeling B and they already got gonna get
town and stuff we got eventually got all
the bits and pieces together and then we
did this I think and how many people
were out there well we invited hundred
people and that was it and
and you got away with it you you were
with you I mean I said earlier you were
named as subversive by the East German
secret police but it wasn't because of
that incident but that that that concert
is actually a sort of legendary moment
because it was the first ever concert I
had such a band by a West Western put me
obviously in East Berlin Leon East
Germany they had like you know boney m
perform on telly they had Western groups
perform in East Germany before on East
Berlin but a punk but Punk didn't exist
officially in East Germany simply for
the reason it was a punk was regarded as
being something which was a failing of
capitalism you know through capitalism
you had punk rock were unemployment and
things and in East Germany being the a
biter and Bauer starts here the worker
and farmer state of unemployment
therefore didn't have punk rock so has
to bring a West German punk rock band
into East Berlin and infiltrate them
into their society that was deemed
something quite colorful and I did well
though at the time we didn't know that
amongst the kids that had been invited
there were a couple of stars ease as
well you know what my informers but they
hadn't informed on the gate prior to the
game because they wanted to see the game
so they decided they after the event a
night in 88 we repeated it's the gig a
gay person this is just before the wall
came but yeah we did we did with a group
called division they they put on a
concert for the orphans and he's in
Romania Romanian orphans that was the
disguise for this concert and so we did
we did another gig like and then of
course the wall fell down and you
weren't here in Berlin I believe when
the Wall fell down yeah I want to move
on to sort of what you said at the end
of that last report you said about trees
all this famous Club there's nothing
going to be like it ever again I mean do
you think I mentioned this because of
the Rolling Stone article a few months
ago which I'm sure you know about where
it said Berlin it's over Berlin is over
it's not the cool city anymore just a
quick answer we've got a report coming
up but a quick answer is do you think
Berlin still cool yes
I think police still clues an
ever-growing coolness Berlin is it
tracks out on different kinds of people
to Berlin for different reasons but
Berlin's always been a good place and
always real beating I think I think that
the the fact that there's or never be
the same the idea of having such a place
will never be the same again because
there's too many rules and regulations
now before you don't have those health
and social won't go there at the moment
okay our reporters went out and about
asking the very same question is
building cool on there not let's see
what others think and we're talk some
more in a minute my typical weeknight in
Berlin people dance and drink until the
wee hours in clubs like saige it's a lot
of activity for a city that's lost its
title as the capital of cool
or is the entire debate nothing more
than a diversion
thinking the things that made Berlin hip
are still here
some people say who needs Berlin but I
say don't believe everything you hear
put down your newspaper come here and
see for yourself in visas the many
millions of tourists who visit Berlin
each year do just that their number is
growing and so is the number of people
who live here even Sofia Berlin's the
coolest and most relaxed city in Europe
in Berlin you can dive into a bunch of
different worlds and cultures cancelin
I'll ask you Jim I like the freedom you
have here you can be anything you want
here it's always changing its permanent
bow Stella bow Stella that's German for
construction site and it's true Berlin
is still changing some mainstays of the
counterculture have closed while others
take their place Berlin's hipster
reputation also owes something to its
thriving contemporary art scene since
the fall of the Berlin Wall the city has
become home to about 440 galleries more
than any other European city an
exhibition in Berlin is a feather in the
cap of any artist
yeda cannot so an offended disbelieve
every generation reinvents berlin and
creates a new city in its own image as
you into Kentucky that's what makes
living here so fabulous every five or
six years Berlin reinvents itself and
you have an entirely new city to
discover Berlin has hundreds of museums
and monuments it also boasts one hundred
and fifty theaters and stages in every
genre and about twelve thousand
restaurants cafes and ice-cream parlors
and then there's the nightlife the
techno club bear cane and the Watergate
are on many a must-see list in the 1990s
after the fall of the Berlin Wall clubs
and bars expanded into the reunified
cities many empty spaces like the techno
club trays are housed in a former
department store today there are fewer
unused spaces and everything is more
regulated
but Berlin remains a city teeming with
possibility there are still many
undiscovered spots in the city with free
spaces for new projects as long as
that's still true people will flock here
and try to make their dreams a reality
this is still a wild and edgy place to
be and there you have it after one day
and one night we have our answer
Berlin still seems to be the capital of
cool
I'm mark reader thinks it is as well
certainly yeah yeah you know it's a
place where you can it's always been
that really building Frick place where
you can have freedom of thought it's
probably the last end clave on this
planet that's really last free really
hmm you have got the countries or the
places where new rules and regulations
kind of like constrict people why is
that though because the impression
perhaps of of Germany and the Germans
from abroad is that they're they like
their ordinal their order and their but
it's not like that here in Berlin is
that not not in in a day to day level I
don't think he's different you know
where it's like in industry maybe you
know it's all documented hmm and that's
what makes it works yeah but the Berlin
is a city Berlin's not on the industrial
city he's a cultural city you know
people say people who want to make money
don't come to Berlin you know really
because it's not that kind of money
generating city where is it also the
capital of techno oh absolutely you know
I mean some people would dispute them
but they'd be wrong to dispute because
because without Berlin there would be no
such thing as technology that did techno
really happen after the fall of the wall
and well with that there's the seeds
were planted before you know kids in
Detroit Jeff Mills and don't many people
like that in Detroit who were listening
to german like electronic music trying
to kind of mix their own things together
they kind of created what we know today
is the kind of root of kept techno but
they didn't have any kind of success in
Detroit on Chicago they came to Berlin
and and because of the wall you know we
had a little scene before the wall came
down
techno fans a couple of hundred people
you know who were interested in what
wasn't the first Love Parade in 1989 all
the water in July yeah but we're talking
200 people
yeah about that were you there yes sir
what are the two I went to and and you
know we we were just a little group of
people having a bit of fun you know we
had no idea how this was going to pan
out and but we learned into a million
people the father's building
was the most important factor for that
you know without the following wall we
probably wouldn't have expanded like it
did and the reason being was because all
these kids in East Germany and East East
Berlin suddenly could choose for
themselves what they wanted to hear what
they wanted to do and it was sex drugs
and techno really you know it was like
here that we had a lot of places which
were suddenly free to to utilize all
along the death strip all these like
derelict buildings which could be
happens in Windows there are no rules
and regulations to palete there were no
police to pull all the rules East German
rules are all been thrown out the window
so people could just do anything and it
was like we won't have a party we want
to take loads of drugs and I've looked
over of a great party on the death strip
you know on it and that and that kind of
transformed this and it wasn't like
because East German kids weren't really
tuned into the like in listening to
English lyrics esle Tolleson techno have
no lyrics it was kind it was just
banging music and it was just like
dancing and it was doing all the things
that you weren't allowed to do in East
Germany hmm and for the Westerners it
was kind of like yeah we knew what it
was about so we could kind of organize
it in a sense and it kind of gelled
really well and that's what created this
techno sing and then other people coming
from elsewhere experiencing it for the
first time all these American DJ's
coming to Berlin to play in this world
it was like you know and then Jellicle
that Tresor which is a on the death
strip in a former safety deposit bank
box thing you know it's like what do you
what do you think I mean I'm sorry it's
not really changing the subject but I do
want to share this very sweet picture of
your mum um and what your mum thought of
all this at that well did she know what
you were up to no it's not just a
beautiful picture of your mother still
doesn't know if I want to you know well
because I actually really only showed
that picture because I really wanted to
show this picture helps please is yeah
is this the eyes how old were you dad
20 yeah this is in Berlin okay that's in
Berlin yeah but and one more I want to
show is of your house in Manchester
which
in Manchester and the sex pills pistols
poster there which I believe a neighbor
objected yeah I'm on the pop you can
hardly see on on that photograph odd and
on the the next door neighbor's window
he's got actually got a picture of the
the Queen yes for the Queen's Silver
Jubilee 1977 and I've got this Sex
Pistols posters look up him in the
window went out on took the photograph I
knew I didn't have long to do this you
know and literally I put it off and then
the next-door neighbor he's seen it he
was a royalist and you know he'd been in
the Royal Marines he called the police
and the police came and maybe mum tell
me to take out the window immediately at
least came in no wonder you left
Manchester I mentioned at the beginning
of the program that your phone book
makes interesting reading one person I
want to ask you about because it's I
read somewhere that you persuaded Nick
Cave to move to Berlin yeah amongst me
and the girls from malaria we kind of
thought sort of like yeah Nick it
actually he come to play a gig in Berlin
played in the music College de glitz and
he'd met this girl called Elizabeth
wrecker who was actually our from the UM
be captain manager of the record label
monogram and they think it was a bit it
was a bit kind of like smitten by her
beauty and her hives resolved and he was
like oh how can i how can I get to
Berlin how we know what's it like living
in Berlin and as we were on tour with
the birthday party
he was constantly asking me you know
what questions like how was it like to
live in Berlin you know how easy its
Italy yeah and I said you just like you
just come you know just just can come
and stay in my flat for a while and say
you can find a flat and that's exactly
what it's only now ring the doorbell and
there you stand a movie or musically
there musically that the one person
perhaps you're associated with perhaps
most of all is Paul fan Duke or as a lot
of people could say Paul van Dyk yeah
but actually in in German his name would
be fan Dookie he's originally from the
east just yet and he's now one of the
biggest DJs in the world and those
probably and are you nurtured his career
for a long time well he came to me as a
young sort seventeen eight
knurled yeah you know he wanted to be a
professional DJ and I said well you know
I longed to do it if you're gonna be the
best DJ in the world or you know I don't
did you did you see something in him
then I did yeah of course you know you
know I gathered yeah and I had another
another artist on my label I've created
a record label off the following one
called which I called mastermind for
success which I shot into NFS the Easter
it was actually born out of the former
East German record label from God at the
Amiga which was like the the the state
of own record label that's Romania
now I produced an album for them the
last album of the DDR for a group called
division and I met everybody who was
involved in this kind of label and when
the wall came down I said well now you
can now you can do something new you
know so they they said okay we have no
idea what you're talking about you do it
and we'll help you you can use all our
facilities so I created this label
mastermind for success which I didn't
tell them was gonna be shortened to em
FS because I thought they'd get upset
about Venus Germans because em FS
actually means ministerium for stats is
your height which is the spazzy right
now I'm with you oh I see that's they
retain their letters m FS but I didn't
know how I was gonna do this without
telling these Germans so I created
masterminded for success as the name of
the label and then use the three letters
as their relation to their horror yeah
there's a different kind of techno there
different kind of terror you know to the
start anyway I had another lip artist
called cosmic baby who was very prolific
and I thought he's good but the DJ his
music he makes isn't DJ friendly he
needs a DJ I'm Paul from Paul van Dyk
just happen to be a DJ one night in a
club and he said I found someone I think
might be good and the things kind of
went from one thing to another and I
decided okay he's got a bit of talent
this kid he's got a focus and I think if
he's ambitious enough he might go for it
I said I only want the best you're not
gonna be the best I'm not gonna do it
for you
well he's become one of the top guys but
I wonder I wonder what you'll make of
this this is Paul find out this is high
opera mixed with beats that I know you
haven't seen because you said before the
program
the aforementioned poor funding it's
Saturday night in Munich the Bavarian
State Opera is staging an open-air
concert as part of the opera for
everyone series a big crowd gathered at
the musicians entrance both opera fans
and techno fans
the latter are here to see power fun
Duke the internationally acclaimed DJ
tonight he will be mixing club beats
with the music of joosep avanthi
the sees that loaches are empty the
audience becomes the show and the opera
stage becomes the dancefloor
that's getting picked up in a club
context it's really about moving and
having fun and I sample Verdi again and
again to show how contemporary his work
still is but the show is very very
different and it's a real challenge to
the 500 tickets available for the show
were sold out shortly after the box
office open the mood was relaxed and the
people seemed to enjoy the concept
Paul Phaneuf is one of Germany's
best-known DJs he's also a pioneer of
electronic dance music his career began
on the Berlin techno scene in the 1990s
since then he's been taking his music on
tour around the world this isn't fun
Duke's first classical experiment in
2009 he worked with Estonian conductor
Pavo yavi in Frankfurt
during the show in Munich electronic
music is followed by classical
interpretations of Verdi
that Robo variance state opera singers
are supporting Fon Dukes work
mr. Luscombe Janos it's brilliant he's
bringing young people into the Opera
House that's usually hard to do and DJ's
come along and say this is a cool
location that brings young people out of
the clubs and into the Opera and we get
opera fans excited about techno beats
now as I mentioned earlier in the
program we've got mark readers latest
album to give away it really is hot off
the press you've brought them in with
him today I haven't listened to it yet
it's still warm in my hand
anyway it's called collaborator and if
you'd like the chance of winning it just
write to us at insite at DW de and
you're going to the draw for a lucky
winner mark tell it I really don't know
anything except there remixes so there's
more it's it's the kind of all the work
that I've done as a kind of
retrospective of like things normally
there's a bit of my old school stuff
like the umber Canton sharp agus music
on there because the guy who runs his
label really wanted that on he wanted
the Pet Shop Boys mix that I did and
there's a few new things that I've done
that the westbam mix I did with them for
best band Bernard Sumner I did the mix
just for this album and there's money
from Ladytron his only and yeah quite a
lot burned some of the things that
Michael Jones
they're simply pop record is this the
way I mean is you doing more music
yourself nowadays yeah yeah I mean the
thing is he's I worked a lot like on
DJ's and running my record label and the
fest and they've got a bit bored without
really because I thought I was putting
too much into other people's careers and
I got asked to do these remixes and it
just kind of went one thing my Eternals
and don't quite a few in the meantime
yeah so you stopped nurturing other
people and you're doing around yeah I
decided to go back to doing what I did
before but I didn't want to quickly Asha
I believe you you're also you're a big
movie fan and I read something you
actually starred in a horror movie I
haven't seen it yes I did it's not
really a horror movie more a horrible
movie it's it's it's horrible in the
sense that's the subject matters a bit
kind of like and controversial yeah it's
about a young lady who you actually know
and although you probably don't know
here she's actually the star of the
movie I'm just her sidekick really in
the film
the movies called that the movies called
necromantic to decrement the subject
matter is appropriately that the spice a
bit controversial it was banned it was
banned for about twenty years
oh right alright now we have a dossier
or the wheel we a file that we send out
to people especially people who've got a
Stasi file no a questionnaire and I do
want to ask you about a couple of them
your favorite German place you put down
as apart from your flat Berlin's museum
insel and the the the mountains in
Bavaria do you go walking in the meadow
but you like I like it but I don't your
wisest German you put down as Karl
Lagerfeld and he kind of surprised me I
think yes I think he's pretty pretty hot
on the mark you know he's seen a lot of
things and he's pretty I like the way
talks I like when he gives interviews
he's really always really articulate and
slide away just like what his image yeah
and he also likes to wear the same thing
all the time like me yeah yeah and and
why do you this is as what I call a
marriage acket I'm wearing that we see
you can you've seen I've seen you in
many pictures is that you're the same
sky long they have a few I like to wear
this yeah your favorite German word is
far guard a rep of art or convects hike
which is an another classic well we've
had this a few times of words that were
sort of made up they put them all
together how would compound words how
would you translate that bicycle repair
kit Oh bicycle repair kit yes thank you
very much
now the best kept secret in Germany
we've got to get this one Rudolf Hess
was accidentally killed by an American
GI according to you yeah is this we kept
we we we don't tell us about that very
quickly we've only got a couple of
minutes to go a friend of mine who was
in the US Army he was a medic in the US
Army he's roommate was on watch when
Rudolf Hess tried to commit suicide and
he went to help Rudolf Hess and in the
process of giving him a heart massage
pushed his hands through his chest and
and that was covered up buddy we cannot
verify this on DW I don't know that but
you cannot nearly but I you know my
friend told me he was okay if he told me
literally quite literally like ten
minutes after it had happened because my
roommate is just killed Rudolf Hess and
then the net then it was came out in the
press that he died you know that that
has a diamond Digby died a fixation by
trying to strangle himself boy in actual
fact the death was occurred because he
crushed his sternum pushed his hands
things yeah best thing about living in
Germany it's relaxing and then the worst
thing about living in German did you
remember what you say now it can be too
relaxing okay what's that
sometimes you know you don't you don't
get to the fight you want to get to
maybe sometimes I think it's other fight
I find Berlin like it's them
of all the places that I've ever visited
it's that it's the most relaxing place
to be even is this kind of like bustling
exciting city and you say visiting but
this is I'm at or home for you isn't it
you're not yeah you're not going
anywhere else I don't think you're with
me no not you know maybe I've not seen
the rest of the world you know I've seen
quite a bit of it well since you know no
I might find Alaska someplace yeah it's
been fascinating talking to you about
Berlin and all that you've done here and
the music scene here and everything
thanks very much for being with us
can I just remind everybody to write in
again in sight at DWD e if you're
interested you can just write to us and
comment on the show and you can go go
into the draw for collaborator mark
readers latest album it's a fascinating
album as as you've mentioned Pet Shop
Boys Byrne and some are Dion but can
turn your band the remix as well
and shark Vegas and lots lots more
that's it from me thanks for watching
and I'll see you at the same time next
week